there is a reaction there that allows us to
count on the start of a serious
conversation, but there is no positive reaction on secondary issues
on the main issue in this document,
and the main
issue, I remind you, is our clear
position on the inadmissibility of further
expansion of NATO to the east and the deployment of
strike weapons that could
threaten the territory of the Russian Federation is
indicative  that now, when our Western colleagues react to our
proposals to agree on legally
binding guarantees for the Euro-Atlantic,
they always
call for the implementation of the agreed
principles regarding the
security architecture in the euro from the Atlantic and
immediately say that this means NATO has the
right to expand, no one has the right
to forbid NATO to consider the
appeal of any other side principle
according to which it is impossible to strengthen one's
security at the expense of the security of others is
deliberately hushed up and not the
Istanbul Declaration, not the declaration of
Astana by our Western partners in
discussions, but the European Union  the security that is
currently taking place is not mentioned
diligently avoids we
cannot accept such a situation, I asked in
Geneva when we were negotiating with Anthony
Blinky to us how they can explain their
position according to which they consider the
obligations adopted within the framework of the lunch
obese solely as a menu from which
they choose only  what is tasty for
them and what they have committed to do in
terms of the interests of others, they
are simply trying to ignore and
chat, so in the near future,
so that whoever is not blinkin, by the way,
didn’t answer this question to me, he
shrugged his shoulders and that’s all